un poteau une transversale pour
versailles du côté des guingampais un
coup franc légèrement détournée qui
termine au fond des filets les dieux du
football ont choisi leur vainqueur pour
ce 32e de finale de coupe gambardella
organisé au stade de porchefontaine les
versaillais en manque de réussite
s'incline 1 0
le réalisme d'un mois on a deux bars et
ça s'arrange pas eux ils ont eu un coup
franc il le met c'est dommage mais c'est
le foot on voit que c'était pas si
serein que ça en deuxième mi temps
notamment surtout à la fin où ça
commençait il a du mal à relancer eux
également donc c'est dommage je reste
frustré parce que un poteau une barre
une action un peu litigieuse à la fin on
se dit que on se dit qu'il y avait
peut-être la place de de passer écrit
l'export un exploit que l'efs ces
versets pensionnaire de r2 pensait tenir
jusqu'à la 63e minute et ce but marqué
par guingamp l'équipe nationale qui joue
deux échelons au-dessus dé versailles et
un motif de satisfaction pour le club
qui jouait son tout premier 32e de
finale de coupe gambardella de son
histoire
il en est fier c'est un centre de
formation une vision entraînements tous
les jours nous en enquillant trois
enfants par semaine c'était cette
dernière semaine et huit blessés on est
pas en complet gris comme à tenir parce
que pratiquement tout le match on a 2
bat donc le web on est fier je suis fier
je suis fier de l'équipe après cette
désillusion versé se concentre déjà sur
d'autres objectifs une victoire en coupe
de paris une montée en dh et versés sont
à l'heure actuelle 4e du championnat de
r2 à un point de la deuxième place